A LOT OF PEOPLE GETTING PRETTY
UPSIDE ABOUT THESE LOCKDOWNS
ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
BECAUSE THE GOALPOSTS SHIFT,
WELL, IT STAYS ALL ACROSS THE
COUNTRY ARE GETTING ANTSY AND
AMERICANS WANT TO GET BACK TO
WORK AND THE GOVERNORS AND
STATES THAT HAVE LARGELY
CONTROLLED THE OUTBREAK AND WE
DIDN’T SEE MUCH OF AN OUTBREAK
AT ALL ARE MAKING PLANS TO JUST
DO THAT.
WELL, TEXAS FOR EXAMPLE RELEASED
A ROLLING TIMELINE FOR LISTING
CORONAVIRUS RESTRICTIONS ON
APRIL 20TH AND REOPENING STATE
PARKS ON APRIL 22ND AND REMOVING
SOME RESTRICTIONS ON ELECTED
SURGERIES ON APRIL 24TH, RETAIL
STORES CAN START OFFERING TO GO
SERVICES.
ON APRIL 27TH, THE GOVERNOR WILL
UNVEIL MORE DETAILS ON THINGS
LIKE THEATERS AND RESTAURANTS.
PRESIDENT AND CEO OF MINNESOTA’S
CAMBRIA.
LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR, STARTING
WITH YOU AND CRITICS ARE SAYING
THAT YOU ALL HAVE THE TENTH
HIGHEST NUMBER OF CASES IN THE
COUNTRY.
SO WHY ARE YOU READY TO GET THIS
REOPENING THING GOING?
>> WELL, WE ARE WATCHING, LAURA,
THE HOSPITALIZATION AND THE
DEATH RATE AND I DON’T KNOW IF
I’M EXACT ON THE NUMBER BUT I
THINK WHERE THE LOWEST ON CAP
CAPITAL AND DEATH AND WE HAD
9 MILLION CITIZENS AND 1400
DEATHS AS OF TODAY.
SO I CITIZENS ARE DOING RIGHT
AND WHAT WERE DOING UNDER THE
MILLIONS OF PEOPLE AND EVERY
LIFE IS PRECIOUS AND VALUABLE
AND WE DON’T DIMINISH THIS
BUDGET TEXANS ARE READY TO GET
BACK AT WORK.
WE ARE ROLLING OUT SLOWLY AND
SAFELY AND WE GOT TO GET BACK TO
WORK AND DO TWO THINGS BACK AT
ONCE AND TEXANS ARE READY TO GET
BACK AND WE ARE LEADING THE WAY.
>> Laura: MARGATE, MINNESOTA
IS A VERY INTERESTING STATE FOR
A LOT OF REASONS AND I LOVE
MINNESOTA.
BUT YOU COMPARATIVELY HAVE FEW
COVID DEATHS THANKFULLY.
BEEN ABLE TO CONTROL THIS PRETTY
WELL.
YET, YOU HAVE A PRETTY SERIOUS
LOCKDOWN EMPLOYEES AND SOMEWHAT
RELAXED WITH GOLF COURSES AS I
UNDERSTAND TODAY THAT’S NICE AND
THAT’S GOING TO BE OPENING.
BUT PEOPLE ARE PROTESTING AT THE
GOVERNOR MANSION AND THEY ARE
SAYING WE ARE DONE WITH THE
SHUTDOWN AND THEY WERE OUT THERE
AND TRUMPS LIBERATING MINNESOTA,
MARTY, WHAT’S GOING ON?
>> IT’S MOVING FAST AND WE WENT
OUT IN THE SHELTER AND HOUSE AND
WE WENT OUT 21 DAYS AND OUR
GOVERNOR DID A REALLY GOOD JOB
IN THE LAST 21 DAYS.
JUST NOW BEGINNING OUR STATE AND
I THINK WHAT IS HAPPENING, IT’S
GETTING LENGTHY TO CONSIDER
STAYING OUT LOUD STOMACH LONGER.
WE HAVE TO GET THE KIDS AND THE
BUSINESSES BACK IN SCHOOL AND
BUSINESSES BACK TO WORK FOR
SURE.
I THINK WHAT ALARMED MINNESOTA
WAS THE REGIONAL PARTNERSHIP
THAT WAS CREATED A COUPLE DAYS
AGO WITH MICHIGAN AND OHIO, AND
KENTUCKY, AND INDIANA, AND
WISCONSIN.
I REALLY THINK THAT THROUGH AN
ALARM TOWARDS MINNESOTA CITIZENS
AND OUR GOVERNOR I THINK IS
CORRECT BUT CLARIFIED FOR US,
LAURA AND THEY’RE GOING TO HAVE
A LEARNING AND A COLLABORATION
THAT ARE GOVERNORS GOVERNING THE
STATE INDEPENDENT WITH REALITY
ON THE GROUND IN MINNESOTA.
HE PROVED THAT TODAY BY OPENING
UP GOLF COURSES, OPENING UP THE
LAKES, FISHING, BIGGER AREAS FOR
MINNESOTA FOR THAT ASPECT.
AS WELL, HE OPENED UP SALES WITH
THAT BILL AND HE SAW THAT OUT OF
OUR AGO.
HE’S GOING TO TURN THE CORNER ON
THAT THING.
HOW YOU COME OUT OF IT.
>> Laura: PEOPLE GET READY
WITH THAT AND DAN, PEOPLE GET
RESTLESS A SEAT IN
HUNTINGTON BEACH, CALIFORNIA,
HUNTINGTON BEACH AND THE
MICHIGAN PROTEST AND THE
PENNSYLVANIA STATE SENATE SAY NO
TO THE GOVERNORS AND VERY
DEVONIAN SHUT DOWN THERE.
AND SOME PEOPLE WANT AND THE
ELDERLY TO BE PROTECTED AND MAY
BE NEW PROTOCOLS FOR A WHILE.
BUT DAN COME A LOT OF PEOPLE
CONCERNED THAT THE NEW NORMALS
THEY SAY WE HAVE TO LIVE IN IS
BASICALLY WHAT THEY ALWAYS
WANTED AND THEY WANTED FEWER
CARS, YOU KNOW, THEY DON’T LIKE
THIS IDEA NECESSARILY OF THESE
TEXANS AND THE FOOTBALL STADIUMS
ALL THE TIMES AND THERE’S A LOT
OF PEOPLE WORRIED THAT THEIR WAY
OF LIFE IS JUST GOING TO GO
ALONG WITH THE VIRUS.
>> WELL, WE WILL GET BACK I
BELIEVE WITH THE PRESIDENT’S
LEAD IN THE PRIVATE SECTOR, WILL
WILL GET BACK TO LIFE AS IT WAS
AND WERE MITIGATING THE PROCESS.
PEOPLE ARE GETTING UPSET WITH
DEMOCRATS IN CONGRESS NOT
SHOWING UP TO DO THEIR JOB WE
NEED THE PPP PROGRAM AND LAURA,
I’M A SMALL BUSINESS PERSON.
BUSINESSES NEEDN’T WEAR OUT OF
MONEY IN THE FUNDS AND IF I’M
REPUBLICANS I WOULD SHOW UP
EVERY DAY IN THE SENATE, IN THE
HOUSE AND SIT AT YOUR DESK AND
SAY WE ARE HERE TO DO THE
PEOPLE’S BUSINESS.
SECONDLY, LAURA, I’M REALLY
TIRED OF NANCY PELOSI AND
CONGRESS BECAUSE YOU KNOW WHAT,
THEY’RE NOT HER BY THIS, LAURA,
THEY MAKE $174,000 A YEAR AND
THEY HAVE NOT HAD THEIR PAY CUTS
AND THEY’RE GOING NUTS AND THERE
AT HOME AND IT’S TIME FOR THEM
TO GET BACK TO CUT AND THEY HAVE
TO TAKE A HALF PAY CUT AND I CAN
SPEAK TO THAT CLEARLY BECAUSE IN
TEXAS, OUR SENATORS AND HOUSE
MEMBERS AND MYSELF MAKE $600 A
MONTH.
WE WERE AT $50 A WEEK AND TENTH
LARGEST ECONOMY WE MEET
EVERYWHERE, IT’S TIME FOR
CONGRESS TO TAKE A PAY CUT AND
SO THEY FEEL SOME OF THE PAIN
THAT PEOPLE AT HOME OR FEELING
BECAUSE CONGRESS ISN’T FEELING
ANY PAIN.
THE PEOPLE IN THE SMALL
BUSINESSES ARE SO GET BACK TO
WORK AND CUT YOUR PAY AND SHOW
YOU’RE WITH US.
>> Laura: GET BACK TO WORK
I’VE BEEN SAYING THIS AND I’VE
SAID THIS FOR A MONTH.
THE STATE HOUSES ALL ACROSS THE
COUNTRY AND CONGRESS SHOULD HAVE
HAD THEREABOUTS IN THEIR OFFICES
DOING THE WORK OF THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
MARTY, VERY QUICKLY, REALLY
QUICKLY YOU HAVE A LOT OF
WORKERS, 900 WORKERS IN YOUR
PLANT IN MINNESOTA.
GIVE ME AN EXAMPLE OF HOW THIS
IS EXPECTING THE AVERAGE.
>> I’LL GIVE YOU A GOOD EXAMPLE
OF WHAT THE GOVERNOR JUST DID
AND I’VE BEEN A EMPLOYEE CALLING
FROM L.A. AFTER THE MAYOR PUT
THE POLICIES IN TWO DAYS AGO AND
SHE SAID, MARTY, I’M NO LONGER
CONCERNED ABOUT LOSING MY LIFE
TO THE VIRUS.
I’M CONCERNED ABOUT LOSING THE
LIFE I’VE BUILT THROUGH THE
LOCKED AROUND AND THE
RESTRICTIONS AND SHE’S A WORKING
MOTHER WITH A 13-YEAR-OLD AND A
2-YEAR-OLD WHOSE WORK YOUR OFF
HER 22 YEARS TO TRY TO BUILD
SOMETHING UP AND NOW SHE’S
LOSING HER EQUITY, LOSING HER
FINANCIAL SECURITY AND SHE’S
LOSING A LOT OF THE VIABILITY OF
HER CAREER AND HER FUTURE
FORWARD FINANCIALLY AND THAT
REALLY PUTS FEAR AND THESE
PEOPLE IN THE STREETS.
>> Laura: THEY WANT TO SAVE
THEIR LIVES, MOTHERS, FATHERS,
SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS, WE ARE
ALL IN THIS TOGETHER AS
AMERICANS AND WE WANT TO PROTECT
AND SAVE LIVES BUT WE WANT TO
SAVE OUR WAY OF LIFE.
I’VE NEVER LIKED THE PHRASE THE
NEW NORMAL AND I’VE NEVER LIKE
THAT PHRASE BECAUSE IF WE
PRETEND SOMETHING’S COMING DOWN
THE ROAD LONG AFTER THE VIRUS IS
GONE.
>> PEOPLE HAVE COMPASSION FOR
THE SECURE, AND IT’S PRETTY
CRUEL TO SAY THAT’S WHAT HE
WANTS TO GET BACK TO WORK DOES
NOT CARE ABOUT THE AFFLICTED.
THAT’S ABSURD TODAY.
>> Laura: I KNOW DAN CARES
ABOUT HIS STATE AND I